PAUL IRISH: Well, hello.
My name is Paul Irish, and I
wanted to share some things
with you about performance,
specifically HTML5, CSS3,
DOM-type stuff about
performance, things happening
in the front end, the browser,
things that could be slow and
could be faster.
And so we're going to talk about
these kind of things.
First we're going to talk
about reflows, hardware
accelerated CSS, animation, web
workers, benchmarking, and
a little bit about
build scripts.
Sound good?
Great.
OK reflows, let's just
look at this diagram.
This is a diagram put together
by Stoyan Stefanov.
When we're talking about
reflows, we're talking about
the render tree.
That's the really
important part.
And the render tree
is made from--
well, it comes from two
different things.
So we have the DOM tree.
The DOM tree is the result after
you tokenize and parse
your HTML markup.
It gets parsed into the DOM.
And that's what you see in
Chrome Developer Tools or
Firebug, all the elements,
right?
Of course.
At the same time, we have
styles coming in.
And so we have styles coming
in from the style
sheets and so on.
And when those two combine,
we get the render tree.
And the difference between the
DOM tree and the render tree
is that the render tree--
let's say that we have an
element that is display:none.
Not present in the
render tree.
So it's in the DOM tree, but
it's not in the render tree
because we don't see it.
It's just not even there.
Or if we manipulate the window
size or change the font size,
the full-page zoom, that, of
course, changes the render
tree most of the time, whereas
the DOM probably is staying
the exact same.
So the render tree is what
you see, and the DOM
is underneath it.
A reflow is a change that
necessitates a recalculation
of the render tree.
And it might recalculate just
the very bottom of it.
But it might recalculate
the entire thing.
And reflows can be cheap.
But at the same time, they
can be expensive.
Specifically on mobile devices
or old IE, they can be quite
expensive, and you don't
want to do a reflow if
you don't have to.
And there's ways
to avoid them.
So first, well, let
me show you this.
This right here--
ah, this is so cool.
This is a debug version
of Firefox, I believe.
And it's actually laying out
the mozilla.org homepage,
calculating the layout and the
position of absolutely
everything.
This is awesome.
It figured out where
it all goes.
And then once it's all done and
the browser's figured out
it, there we go.
Pretty cool.
But let me show you this
one part in here.
It's right about here--
finish off the footer.
And then all of a sudden,
something happens.
And then it has to recalculate
the whole
thing all over again.
And I don't know why
that happened, but
it didn't need to.
And we were basically
done at this point.
And now we have to wait another
30% of our time so
that it can recalculate the
layout of absolutely
everything when it should
have been done.
And so this is the kind of thing
that we want to avoid.
We don't want to have a full
page reflow that invalidates
the entire render tree.
We want to get that finalized
render tree out to the user as
fast as possible so that they
can interact with your DOM.
So what causes reflows?
A lot of people have wondered.
And a lot of people have
thought, well, checking the
element.offsetWidth is
normally the trick.
But Tony G. On the Chrome
team dug into this and
tried to answer it.
So Tony dug in, just opened up
Google Code Search and looked
for Update Layout, Ignore
Pending Style Sheets--
and this is essentially what
does a reflow in WebKit--
and found all these items, and
then just listed them out.
So what we get is this.
These are all the properties
and methods that
will cause a reflow.
And so the offsetWidth, which
is kind of the one that most
people know, that's
certainly here.
But there's a lot
of other ones.
And interestingly, innerText
appears to cause a reflow
whereas innerHTML does not.
I'm not exactly sure
about that.
scrollTo on the window does.
So these are all the things
that by calling, you would
trigger a reflow.
But what are the kind of
typical operations
that would do it?
Of course, manipulating the DOM
tree is definitely going
to cause a reflow.
Yeah, definitely.
If you hide a DOM node with
display:none, that will
manipulate the render tree.
It will cause a reflow.
But then any changes to
that element once it's
display:noned won't.
Whereas over with
visibility:hidden, if you just
take an element,
visibility:hidden it, there's
no recalculation of the page.
The geometry of the page
stays the same.
So actually there's no reflow.
We just repaint that one little
box and keep going.
If we're animating anything
across the page, of course
we're doing reflows.
It depends on maybe you could
overflow:hidden it, a
container, so that it's kind of
encapsulated a little bit.
Adding new styles, and then any
sort of user interaction
like resizing the window,
changing the font size, even
scrolling causes reflows.
So here's a little example about
a small optimization
that you could do to avoid
causing excess reflows.
So what we're doing, this is
just some simple little jQuery
code, right?
We are grabbing an element, and
we're just grabbing the
left style property off of it.
And then we're going to take
that left and apply it to
something else.
And then we have to do that
to another one as well.
So we get it here, set it,
get it here, and set it.
The problem here is that
actually checking our style
property is going to trigger
a recalculation of
the styles in a reflow.
And because we set something
here, it has to
do it all over again.
So a way to avoid this is we
can just bunch our gets
together and then our
sets together.
I'll show you.
This is kind of what it looks
like over in the Chrome Dev
Tools Timeline view.
So here we are.
We have Recalculate
Style and Layout.
And these kind of go together.
Recalculate Style is essentially
the prerequisite
for a reflow.
In WebKit and in other
browsers, a
reflow is called a layout.
Mozilla uses the term
"reflow." It's just
terminology really.
What you'll see here is that in
that first example, we kind
of do this thing twice before
we're able to paint out what
the changes are.
Whereas in the second one when
we bunch them together, we can
get away with just doing
a single reflow
before we're all set.
And then we can paint it out.
And I will point out the scale
looks a little weird here.
But we finished the second time
at about 3 milliseconds.
Whereas the first time we
finished maybe about 4 to 4
and a 1/2 milliseconds.
So the third one, in addition
to having less reflows, is
actually indeed faster.
So there's a few strategies
for avoiding reflows.
The first is batching your
DOM changes together
like we just did.
Other ways we can do it is you
can clone the existing
element, work off DOM with
that element, and then--
because any manipulations while
it's off DOM are not
going to cause a reflow.
And then once you're done
manipulating it, you can
replace that one that was
already there and check the
new one in.
If you hide anything with
display:none, it
will cause a reflow.
But if you then manipulate it,
all those manipulations while
it's display:none will not cause
reflows, except in IE.
However, you can take
an element.
Instead of doing display:none,
you can just take it off DOM,
hold it in documentFragment,
do your manipulations in
documentFragment, and then put
it back in when you're done.
You only get the reflow when
you are manipulating the
actual DOM.
And when things are off
DOM, you're fine.
So that one you're fine in
IE and everywhere else.
Cool?
OK, there's a few more resources
I would like you to
just check out if you're
into this stuff.
Stoyan Stefanov has done
a lot of research
on reflows and repaints.
and so he's got some
great stuff here.
BrowserScope has a few tests to
see what triggers reflows.
Like we were just seeing,
there's a lot of small details
that are different
across browsers.
David Baron had a really great
Google Tech Talk about browser
internals and specifically
aiming that talk at web
developers.
And so this is, I think, an
hour-long talk that you
should check out.
And WebKit, about five years
ago, did a five-part series
about how rendering works.
And it's so cool.
It's from five years ago.
But it's totally
relevant today.
I definitely recommend
checking that out.
OK, I think we're done
with reflow.
Let's move on.
Hardware accelerated
CSS, yeah.
All right, getting into
some sexy here.
So we're just going to skip
right into the demo.
This is Isotope by
David DeSandro.
Let's see, I'm going to change
the sort a little bit.
And then I'm going to insert
some new elements.
Click around here.
Yeah, like this.
This is good.
Even resize the window, and that
responds really nicely.
So what's actually happening
here is that we're actually
using CSS transitions and CSS
transforms to do these changes.
Now, normally you might think
you're going to manipulate the
position of where things go.
And you'll probably be like,
oh, it'll be absolutely
positioned.
And then I'll just manipulate
left and top and tell it where
it's going to go now.
The trick here is that
we're actually using
2D transforms translate.
So we're using
webkit-transform:translate,
and then we're just changing
the x and y of translate.
Then we're also using
a CSS transition.
And as a result, we're able to
get all these operations
hardware accelerated, which
means super-high frame rates,
really high-fidelity animations,
and they look
basically as good as they can.
You're writing it in a
declarative way so that the
browser can be like, oh,
yeah, I got this.
Let me take this.
I'm going to take this down to
my friend the GPU and optimize
this for you.
And so it's going to
look really good.
The cool thing here in Isotope
is that David wrote it in a
way that it can detect support
for transforms and
transitions.
And if there's not support,
then it'll go back to a
jQuery-based animation style.
So if your browser is new and
good, we're going to do the
right thing.
And if it's a bit older, it'll
still look OK, but not as high
fidelity as possible.
So this is kind of the power
of animations of
hardware-accelerated CSS.
Now, those were 2D transforms,
and everything was just moving
around on a 2D plane.
And normally, 2D transforms and
operations on the 2D plane
don't get hardware-accelerated
by browsers and by WebKit
specifically.
But there's a trick.
And there's a trick to make
the browser do it.
Let me show this clip
from Remy Sharp.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-OK what I'm about to show
you is a CSS animation.
And it's engaged using
JavaScript and just the normal
touch gestures.
But the first effect I'm going
to show you now is one without
a 3D transform.
So this is just doing a scale
and nothing else.
And you see it's just
a little bit jumpy.
That's the actual animation
jumping.
And if I show you the same
version but just with the
translate3d set on the element
that I'm zooming, you can see
it's completely smooth.
And all I've done is
said the image--
so the image element that I'm
pinching and zooming on, I've
just added a CSS property
to say translate 3D.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Yeah, so that's it.
It's kind of a total hack.
You can use either WebKit
transform, translateZ(0) or do
translate3d.
Depending on your use case, one
will probably make more
sense for you.
And all of a sudden, the
browser's like, oh, cool.
Let's throw this on the GPU.
And as a result, we can get
much higher-fidelity
manipulation on the 2D
plane, just like
we saw in this video.
It's pretty cool.
There's a few really good ways
when you're working with this
kind of stuff to debug it
a little bit better.
Over in Safari, there's a
development flag to turn on
some colors.
This actually stands
for core animation.
I'm going to load this up over
the iPhone simulator.
And I'm actually going
to load this page.
This is a tutorial on HTML5Rocks
by Malte Ubl.
And we're going to show
this little demo here.
And what we're actually doing is
we're detecting support for
CSS transitions and
transforms.
And if we have support, we're
just going to use a transform
along with the transition.
Otherwise, we use
jQuery animate.
So here in Chrome, we're using
a transition transform.
And you see that moves
across the screen.
I'm going to show this in
the iPhone simulator.
You can see the OS
is accelerated.
Scroll down, here we go.
So I'm just going to click.
And you'll see-- yeah.
And the trick here is that
we actually use that
translateZ(0)--
we call it the silver
bullet here--
trick to make that hardware
acceleration happen.
Over in Chrome, we have a
somewhat similar thing.
Over in about:flags, we
have this setting.
And let me bring this up.
In about:flags, there's a bunch
of really crazy stuff.
I recommend you dig into
this some time.
We have composited render
layer borders.
And well, let me just show
you what it does.
Here's this presentation that
we've been looking at but with
this setting turned on.
And you can see we get borders
around of all the layers that
are composited.
Pretty cool.
So this helps a lot to just
verify that yes, this actually
is being composited
on the GPU.
And then also in this 3D case,
we have a nice little debug
view of what's going on.
I will point out that this
used to happen as a
command line flag.
So it didn't used to be nice and
handy in this about:flags.
But yes, it used to have to run
the Chrome executable with
a command line flag.
And this page over on Peter
Beverloo's site maintains a
list of all the active command
line switches or flags.
And so I recommend you
checking this out.
One of the ones in here
is a show-paint-rects.
And so this actually draws
little borders whenever a
section of the DOM
gets repainted.
Why that's interesting is
because you want to know--
kind of when we were talking
about reflows, you want to
know exactly how much of the
DOM is being invalidated or
the render tree is
being invalidated
when there's a change.
And so with show-paint-rects,
you can see that when you make
a change, only the part that
needs to be recalculated and
repainted is being changed
rather than a much larger
chunk, which would be
kind of unexpected.
So show-paint-rects is another
very helpful flag to use when
you're debugging some of this
advanced rendering stuff.
This tutorial has a number of
other recommendations around
graphics optimizations that
you can make and also digs
into JavaScript profiling.
So dig into that a little bit
more if you're looking to eek
out some better performance of
your HTML5 app and these
recommendations are not
good enough for you.
But next we're going to dig into
requestAnimationFrame.
So requestAnimationFrame
basically came about because
browsers were like, hey, we
know that you're doing
animation in the browser.
And we know that you're just
abusing setTimeout and
setInterval loops to do it.
And that's not cool.
It's not really cool.
Because you know what?
A browser can optimize animation
better than you
writing a setInterval loop, just
trying to peg the CPU as
fast as it will go.
Browser is smarter.
So one of the things that it can
do is it can batch things
into a single reflow
and repaint cycle.
So let's say that you had a
JavaScript-based animation.
You had an absolute position
element, and you're updating
the left and top or something
like that.
The browser can now synchronize
that along with
the concurrently running
CSS transition.
Or if you had some SVG SMIL
animation running at the same
time, it can kind of make sure
that those are all going at
the same time.
It's going to optimize it for 60
frames per second, which is
the refresh rate of
most displays.
And so you're going to get the
best frame rate possible.
60 Hertz is kind of the perfect
target for everything
that you want going
on in the browser.
And the really cool thing is
that you're really friendly to
your users' batteries.
Because what happens is that if
the tab is not visible, it
gets skipped.
So let me load this
up right here.
This is a--
whoa!
Yeah, OK, here we go.
So we got this WebGL demo.
And you see here we got a lot
of action over on the GPU.
And this is the JavaScript
running inside this page.
It's pretty heavy.
Gonna move this around.
Now I'm just going to switch
to another tab.
You see that instantly
dropped.
Because the
requestAnimationFrame is being
used, the browser is like,
hey, you're not even
viewing this tab.
We don't need to be wasting the
browser, the CPU, the GPU
in order to make this happen
because we know that they're
not looking at it.
Whereas if this field demo had
been using a timer loop, it'd
still be going.
It would still be eating
down my battery here.
So I bring that back up.
And our use of the
CPU returns.
So if you're doing any
sort of animation,
use this if you can.
This actually just
landed in jQuery.
So this is going to
be in jQuery 1.6.
And it's also in Grit.
And it's in a few other
libraries at this point.
So I definitely recommend it.
This is available in both
Chrome and also in
Firefox, Firefox 4.
Over on my blog, we have a
nice little shim layer to
handle this.
We basically feature detect
to see if the
native support is present.
And if not, we're going to use
a setTimeout loop that
optimizes for 60 frames
per second.
And that's how you use it.
Cool.
Web Workers, the idea here--
and I don't want to cover
this too much.
The idea with Web Workers that
you're probably familiar with
is we want to move heavy
computation, expensive tasks
outside of the UI thread.
Pretty much all JavaScript
runs in the UI thread.
And if something is taking a
long time, the user can't
interact with the page.
The page becomes
non-responsive.
And in the case of Chrome, we
get a sad, freezing cold tab.
He's so cold.
And we don't want that.
No, that's bad.
And we want to avoid that.
And without Web Workers,
we can.
I'm going to show this.
This is a little bit more
advanced use of Web Worker.
But I think it's really cool.
First, normally the way that
you instantiate a brand-new
Web Worker is you would
be like, new Worker,
myworker.js, there.
This is where the code
is going now.
You pass it a file name.
And then it goes and
gets that file.
And then it uses that file.
And that's your worker.
It has its limitations.
This here is an example
of creating a
worker on the fly, basically.
So here we have-- oops--
our worker code, and it's
a script of type worker.
So this is going to get skipped
by the browser.
So we're just kind of using it
to hold some text right now.
And then down here on our
script, we're going to
use the file API.
And we're going to use
BlobBuilder, create a new
BlobBuilder.
Then we're going to grab the
text of this script node,
throw that into the blob.
And then when we create our
worker, we're going to use
URL.createobject URL with the
blob, and check that in.
Essentially, we create a file
on the fly and then
instantiate the worker
with that.
And so now we have the advantage
of having a little
bit more control over the worker
in case we want to
change it or something
like that.
And then also we avoid
an HTTP run trip.
So from a network layer,
we're a little bit more
optimized as well.
So that is just kind of a cool
example of where you can go
with workers combined
with the file API.
Some places where you might
want to use workers, text
formatting of a long document,
syntax highlighting maybe,
maybe not, depends
on your use case.
If you're doing heavy image
processing or dealing with
large arrays, also the audio
API, for instance, the WebKit
Web Audio API or the Mozilla
Audio Data API, depending on
kind of the analysis that you're
running, a worker might
make sense.
Also, the FileSystem API, which
is available in Chrome,
has had support for workers
for a while now.
And this is really good.
You might be dealing with large
binary data, and you
don't want that holding up
the UI thread at all.
You want to just let that
happen as it does.
And so letting Web Workers
handle the interaction with
the file system is the right
way to go there.
Cool.
Want to touch on JSPERF
real quick.
Yeah, this is real cool.
So JSPERF, if you don't
know, is a site
for performance tests.
And so we have a few things
going on here.
We have a nice human
readable URL.
And oftentimes, with a URL like
join-concat, this is now
the definitive join versus
concat string
concatenation test.
And there's revisions as well.
So within the page we have our
variations of the code that we
want to test.
So this is the age-old
concatenation with plus equals
or array.join, which
is faster.
And I believe it's IE 6 and 7
are faster with the array
join, and absolutely everyone
else is faster with a
straight-up concatenation
augmented in a string.
So don't use a array.join
anymore.
But the nice thing here is that
we can run the test and
get our results and figure
out kind of what it is.
And so the site is used
by a lot of people.
In fact, jQuery has been
using it for the
library development recently.
So let's say there's
a few different
variations of DOM traversal.
The nice thing here is that we
can do our tests with a few
variations, kind of see what's
going on, and then the results
get reported to BrowserScope,
which kind of handles what
user agent it's coming from,
what are the numbers, and kind
of give us a really
comprehensive table of what
the story is across all browsers
and where is each
thing faster.
And so I'm running it here.
This is WebKit Nightly.
And we see, well, in this case,
we have these traversal,
and we have some different
results.
So JSPERF is really good.
I like it a lot because it's
kind of like the clearinghouse
of performance best practices.
People will say, oh, well, you
should use triple equals
instead of double equals
because it's faster.
And now we can actually find
out, hey, are they right?
And are they right across
all browsers or not?
It's powered by benchmark.js,
which is a very finely tuned
and calibrated benchmarking
script that works not only in
the browser but in Node and
Narwhal and Ringo and all
these different environments
and is definitely the right
way to be benchmarking different
variations of code.
So a quick touch on the
HTML5 Boilerplate.
It's a project that
I work with.
And recently, we put
out a build tool.
The build script is just
an Ant script.
But the cool thing is that when
you use it alongside one
of the web server
configurations, like for
Apache or Nginx, you're
basically going to get a 90%
on your score for Google
PageSpeed or YSlow.
There's all these things
that you've heard.
And you're supposed to be
doing like combining and
minifying your JavaScript,
your CSS, your image
optimization.
And the script does
all these things.
It also does HTML
minification.
It revs your file names so that
we can cachebust when
there's a new version.
And then we upgrade the web
server configuration to use
far Future and Expires headers
because now we have unique
file names.
So it does all these
things for you.
And we can basically take what
was a C and B grade website
and bring it up to some
much higher scores.
So I definitely recommend you
dig into that if you'd like to
not have to repeat all these
performance optimizations
every time you make a site.
And let a script handle
it for you.
All right, I guess
that's it for me.
If you have any questions, you
can leave a comment or hit me
up on Twitter.
I'd also recommend to check
out html5rocks.com.
We have a lot of tutorials on
there of really good stuff.
And we have a lot that are
focused on performance and a
lot of the things that I've been
talking about here, so
plenty more to read
and learn there.
So I guess that's it.
Thank you very much
for watching.